[Music]  whoops Bella Hadid falls victim to the  dreaded nip slip it's so crazy the model  strutted her stuff on the runway in  Paris on Tuesday seemingly unaware that  she had suffered a wardrobe malfunction  freeing the nip in front of a crowd of  onlookers still the 21 year old looked  fierce as she served some major face  rocking a black bustier bodysuit with a  teal wrap and lengthy train complete  with a pair of tiny rectangular black  shades and sky-high stiletto heels it  was perfect but Hadid is no stranger to  flashing her assets on the catwalk I  guess I'm doing something right last  July she wore a sheer top with no bra  during Paris Fashion Week and she  regularly sports bra free ensembles  [Music]